hi guys i'm fiona rutherford with
bloomberg quick take
and today is world financial planning
day so we have
two incredible women with us we have
bulla soul
who is a financial wellness coach we
also have
selena flavius who is the founder of
black girl finance so
thank you both for being with us thank
you for having me
so i'm going to jump right into it
you're a financial
wellness coach and for people watching
who might not
really understand what financial
well-being is
can you talk a little bit about what
that means to you what
why are you so passionate about um
financial wellness
yeah i think that sometimes when we
think about finances
we go straight to people who have
a particular amount of net worth or
finances
and what i want is for every woman
especially to be confident in their
financial position
and know what's going on with their
money and there's a lot of anxiety
around money and i want to take that
away by also asking people how are you
looking after yourself
during this time so some people for
example when they're in debt i say
um how are you still enjoying yourself
what are you doing for your health
what are you doing for your well-being
so that's where it comes from
and do you have like a personal story of
how
this became such an important topic for
you
yeah there's definitely been times
through my adventures where
i have not had a lot of money
and it hasn't made me feel great and i
said i
don't want to feel that way and i want
to encourage others not to feel that way
as well because
you never want to put a number on your
value
so i said i don't want people to feel
like that either
thank you and selena you founded
black girl finance which as the name
suggests is focused on
black women so can you talk a little bit
about that and you have a book coming
out as well
so we'd love to hear about that yeah so
um so my name's selena i created the
financial coaching platform called black
golf finance and
one of the key reasons why i created the
platform was because of the statistics
around
um you know the agenda and ethicity pay
gaps you know i wanted to provide a
useful tool
again similar to bola um you know
that's focused on financial wellness
getting rid of anxiety when it comes to
money so i currently work with women who
may be experiencing anxiety around money
perhaps they're struggling with death or
perhaps they are
struggling to hit a kind of a goal that
they want so a lifestyle goal
so perhaps trying to get a property
ladder or saving to retrain
um to have their dream career um so
that's where black gold finance comes in
and yes um i do have
come now in january it's called black
girl finance let's talk money and it's
all about um
personal finance tips to allow you to
not just kind of
deal with anxiety and stress that comes
with being in debt
um but also to thrive when it comes to
money and it's particularly
focused towards the black and blame
community
uh due to those gaps that that
unfortunately um we experienced
and you know you mentioned the pay gap
people don't really talk about
the ethnicity pay gap as well um so
that's such an important
topic um but bala you mentioned anxiety
and i relate so much
because i was in a situation where i
was in so much debt and i just couldn't
really face it
um and i think right now looking at
the fact that we're living in a pandemic
um what would you say to people
especially women who are experiencing
financial hardship right now
you know facing evictions or may have
lost their job
can you still plan during a time like
this
absolutely but i think that you have to
get
super creative right and you have to
look for different sources of
income so whether that's joining
websites such as fiverr.com
and maybe you read through people's work
if you write blog posts for people
um if you do an uber driving if you have
access
to a car or any form of delivery job
you just i think now's the time to get
creative with how you earn money maybe
you can teach classes online that is the
new thing
um just just get creative and make sure
that you can cover your bills and also
remember to lean on your support system
as well
at times i think we especially as women
black women
have this desire to do it all but
lean on your support system that's so
important so
leaning on your support system and get a
side hustle which
is i guess it's fun right getting a side
hustle and
making money through doing things you
love um but what would you say selena do
you think that
um you can still plan during times like
this and is it okay to maybe
dip into finances or your savings
during hardships um
i think i completely 100 agree with
everything that bothers mentioned
you know on my mobile phone and it's
part of the workshop that i taught
um at the beginning of the year having a
side hustle and side hustle folder
and then there was um you know getting
creative like what i said
you know making sure you're on fiverr
you're on you know amazon flex you're on
wherever you can fight five is your
dimension to to make sure that you are
earning extra income
and also another tip i would give is
just to block out all of the noise
because you can read the newspapers
you know see social media and and you
can become disheartened by
all of the kind of negativity that's in
the press around you know
money and finances and not being able to
get on the property ladder and
first-time buyers and all of that kind
of stuff
um you know but just really focusing on
your own personal
financial situation and circumstances
and if you have been
um able to say perhaps you've been still
still in work
been able to you know benefit from the
furlough scheme
which is now coming to an end but
perhaps you've had that that period of
time that
bit of buffer if you have been able to
save then you know if you need to
dip into that kind of emergency fund
that you've been saving then
you know you need to do that um if
there's
no other option and and also what god
has said about leaning on
um your resources and people
that you have available to you that's
also very important
so um one of the things i suggested on
another panel talk was you know if
you're a young person
and struggling with you know maybe
paying rent or
paying rent and kind of housing costs
that tends to be what
you know the most expensive bill that a
lot of us have and
if you if you are able to why not
think about moving back home just
temporarily just so that you've got that
stress
off so definitely relying on resources
becoming creative
also just blocking out the noise and
it's focusing
on financial circumstances i think it's
super important for people to
do there is a lot of pressure to
have a house have like all the clothes
you want go on holidays so
yeah i completely agree but one thing
i've noticed on both of your
instagram accounts actually you talk
about paying yourself fast
actually mean vola yeah so paying
yourself
first means don't pay the retailers
because it's something that we can all
do is your savings in a good place
is your emergency fund in a good place
how are your debts are they
are they cleared are you taking care of
them how is it reflecting in your credit
score for example
it's so easy for us to say oh my gosh i
want this and oh my gosh i want that one
of the things i do sometimes
is i just have baskets and wish lists
and if the time comes
and my budget for it then i'm happy to
spend on it but in general
i don't um i ensure that i pay myself
first
and i make sure that i'm getting the
best rate of interest i can get for
myself and
that i have all the questions in the
world because we are basically
in well in the uk we are in a recession
so
we absolutely need to prepare for that i
agree what do you think selena
is that what you do it's what i live by
i do it myself i go on about it
constantly every kind of beginning of
the month
and you know payday is safe day for me
and
you know i'm a lot better off for it the
period of time whereby
i wasn't saving um didn't have a budget
and
these things should be all done within a
budget so if you
do have debts or if you are building up
an emergency fund you know make sure you
budget
budget it all put it all in your budget
um
because i think you can get thrown off
you know if things are not kind of
allocated properly or fought about in
advance i think you can
easily become you know thrown off your
financial management can be thrown off
you know perhaps if you suddenly come
into you know some money
and then you just decide to throw it on
your debts without being considering you
know your essential bills
or um you know fun kind of stuff that
you might want to
have for a period of time it can really
throw off so i think you know
building up an emergency fund and also
you know paying down those
high expensive debts within a budget is
probably the best approach rather than
just
you know throwing things you know willy
nilly here there and and the other
i think that's important as well but
yeah definitely pay yourself first
when i used to try and save after payday
i had no
chance because i'd be thinking about the
things i wanted to buy last month
um and buying the month and then
everything would just be thrown off
completely so
i think paying yourself first 100
so paula you mentioned wish list so i
have an issue because
there are lots of things i want but how
do you actually stop yourself from
buying it do you just keep them in a
in your basket and just kind of wish
that you had them or like
how do you get that personally how do
you have the self-control to not
buy especially with things like that by
now pay later schemes uh
it's so tempting to just click buy
yeah i think it's about having the
discipline and
knowing the difference between needs and
wants for example how is this going to
contribute towards your life
um and even when it does come into your
life is it
is it a sense of immediate gratification
or is it something that you find
would you still want it in a month is it
just for a is it a quick turnaround
you have to decide these things for
yourself so
um one of the things i do is i have wish
lists and i have baskets and then
if i come back by payday and things are
gone then i know
that um i didn't really want it that
much um
because if i did i would have found the
money for it after i've taken care of
essential pills
prioritizing it's really an important
point
um so selena we spoke before about so i
wrote an essay recently
um for slaying your lane's latest
anthology called loud black girls
and i spoke about how
financial self-care and when i started
practicing financial self-care it was so
empowering for me and i think a lot of
people talk about
financial planning and they think
savings but
savings is financial planning is more
than just savings right would you agree
yeah 100 yes and um
you know my background is my my mum from
the caribbean and she raised me etc
so and she had to establish herself when
she came over
and for her you know her message to me
was always um
save and save you know make sure you
stay for a rainy day
but um a lot of us who are perhaps
second and you know
sorry first and second generation um you
know
people now living in the uk um we don't
experience that same type of rainy day
that perhaps our parents would have
experienced
so you know i didn't suffer the way that
my mum suffered or experienced kind of
poverty or anything like that that she
may have experienced so
um it's about not just
um saving for a rainy day but how can we
make our money work for us
and i think that's super important again
back to the you know ethnicity
and gender pay gaps you know if we are
earning less
unfortunately um we need to make sure
that we're
making our money work well for us when
we do earn it so
looking at things such as you know
invest in once you've got everything in
place once you've got your emergency
fund
you know perhaps you've paid off your um
you know high interest debts
and then you can start investing and
making sure
that your money is working for you um
and benefiting from
compound interest um i think that's
super important not to
kind of take it to the next level um
into how
what our parents taught us in terms of
just saving and taking it to the next
level
follow that's what rich girl chronicles
is about right
could you talk a little about about that
and that space you've created
yeah so rich girl chronicles started
two years ago and i wanted to set up an
accountability group
for women to discuss finance in a social
way
so one of the things i do is i start by
asking people weekly
how are you feeling about your finances
because some people say oh my gosh it
was my
birthday i have absolutely splurged out
and then instead of making it a moment
of judgment i say right
what did you spend your money on and
what you know did you have a great time
was it good and things like that and say
okay so you just have to make some
cutbacks this month
you just say but just remember that i
always say like everybody has a few of
those moments where they do splurge and
i just say
it's not the end of the world don't
punish yourself how do we
regroup so that's what rich girl
chronicles is about being accountable
with your money
so every month we check budgets and we
talk about credit saving debt
i encourage people to look at their
report although some of them wants to do
it i encourage people to look at their
score
i encourage you i encourage people to
ask more money at their job
um of course we've been doing this for a
while so it was
before a recession and um the furlough
scheme but
yeah i try to just encourage just
general financial confidence in women to
make decisions that work best for them
and to learn financial boundaries as
well with family and friends
i love that because it's about creating
the life that you want for yourself and
using money as a tool and having that
social
kind of accountability group i think is
a great idea so so it's coming up to the
end of our
conversation so for the people watching
what should their biggest
takeaway message be from this
conversation selena you go first
yeah so biggest takeaway would be to
really look at your own individual
circumstances and prioritize
you know if you are struggling um with
with money at the moment prioritize
building up that saving pot
prioritize um you know earning extra
income being creative as paula said
um and yeah and paying down any
uh high interest debts that you may may
have prioritize those three things and
then
hopefully by the end of covid you can
thrive financially you can start
you know invest in um and moving things
forward
leveling up finances essentially
definitely
and voila takeaway message
yeah i definitely say learn to invest
even if you start with a virtual
portfolio
it's absolutely important that you learn
to invest because
the way the interest rates are going
right now it's not going in anyone's
favor
even from a savings perspective so look
at ways that
you can learn to invest and like i said
you can start with a virtual portfolio
on apps such as trading 212
and look at your your think about your
level of risk your attitude towards risk
and just go from there
amazing well i certainly feel inspired
to
get my finances in order and i hope
everyone watching feels inspired so
thank you for watching and thank you to
bola and selena for joining me today
thank you take care take care
bye